Are you struggling to engage readers
with your essays, newsletters, and
reports? Even though you're following
all the rules of writing, most experts
when they start writing online, they
look for guidance from writing mavens,
guide books, or even chat GBT. They
follow generic advice, but their writing
doesn't work. Meanwhile, you see thought
leaders in your space go viral with
poorly written slop, and you think, "How
are they getting away with it?" Well,
the reason is easy to see when you read
these two sentences. As an English
professor, let me tell you that these
are my favorite sentences. Bees make
honey and honey is made by bees. Which
sentence is better? Well, if you ask
these writing mavens, then they'll tell
you that bees make honey is better. And
their belief rests on two assumptions.
Both of them are wrong. First, shorter
sentences are better than longer ones.
So, bees make honey is obviously shorter
than honey is made by bees. And the
second faulty assumption is active verbs
are better than passive verbs. And if
you know a little bit about grammar,
then you know that this first sentence
is written in the active voice and the
second sentence is written in the
passive voice. And it's this kind of
thinking that holds so many experts
back. If you're using writing
professionally, maybe you're trying to
build a personal brand or convert leads
into customers, maybe you're trying to
publish your research or just influence
the conversation in your space through
thought leadership content, then there
are two big dangers with following these
rules that you need to watch out for.
And if you want to become a better
writer, then you are going to love my
free newsletter, Writer Science. Link is
down below the like button. So, what are
the two dangers of following this kind
of rules-based writing advice? And how
can you fix it? Well, for the first
danger, consider what happens when
readers read your sentence. They don't
read it all at once. They proceed
through it in time from left to right.
So, they start off with bees. And it's
like, "Okay, tell me about bees. What
about bees?" And then they go on, "Well,
bees make." All right. What do bees
make? Oh, they make honey. So because
readers are moving through your sentence
from left to right, beginning to end,
naturally they take whatever occurs at
the beginning of the sentence to be the
thing that the sentence tells a story
about. That's why we call the position
at the start of the sentence, the topic
position. It's what the sentence is
about. So, no matter which sentence is
longer or which sentence uses passive
verbs, readers perceive sentence one to
be about bees and they perceive sentence
two to be about honey. All right, but
what's this got to do with which
sentence is better? Well, just think
about the readers of this sentence. What
do they care about? Some readers can be
different. Some of them care about bees
and others care about honey. So, put
yourself in the position of those
different readers. Like imagine that you
care about honey. That you want to know
about honey. That's why you're reading.
And then imagine that you're given a
sentence about bees. This isn't what you
care about. It's not what you want to
know about. It's not what you want to
read about. Now, if you do read the
sentence, and let's be honest, you might
not because you really don't care about
bees. It's not what you came for. Then
you need to work harder to find the
information that matters to you. Like
now you've read a sentence about bees,
but you want to think about honey. So in
order to think about what you care
about, you've got to translate this
sentence about bees into a sentence
about honey. That translation process is
a bit of extra work that makes the
sentence seem less clear, less
persuasive, and especially less
valuable. So the question about which
sentence is better is actually a
question about which sentence is more
valuable to your particular reader. So
never mind what the writing mavens say.
There are tons of situations in which
honey is made by bees is the better
sentence. And I know that comes as a
shock to many people. So let's be really
clear about this. Yes, this sentence is
longer and yes it uses a passive verb.
But it's a better sentence because it's
a more valuable sentence to certain
readers. So if you care about rules,
then shorter is better or avoid passives
is a neat and tidy rule. But if you care
about readers, then the longer sentence
with a passive verb may well be more
clear, more organized, more persuasive,
and most importantly, more valuable. So
that's the first danger of rules-based
writing advice. It results in writing
that's not valuable to your readers. But
before we get into the second danger of
following rules-based writing advice,
you've got to know how to fix it so you
don't wind up making your writing worse
by forcing readers to read about
something that they don't care about.
Whenever I work in my private
consultancy with B2B founders, for
example, they endlessly write to clients
with sentences like, "This new feature
permits businesses to da da da." And
most founders who start working with me
do so because they know that their
writing isn't having the desired effect
on their clients. Their writing follows
all the rules, but it just doesn't work.
But what they don't know is that all
these writing rules about shorter
sentences and passive verbs can actually
be part of the problem rather than part
of the solution. Without consciously
deciding to do so, readers of English
will take this to be a sentence about
the new feature. But the number one rule
of marketing is of course don't sell
features, sell benefits. So almost
certainly the client doesn't care about
the feature, doesn't want to think about
the feature, and doesn't want to read
about the feature. Clients care about
many things, but again, in this B2B
space, it's a pretty solid bet that the
client is a business, and what they care
about is themsel. So clients will very
likely find the sentence to be more
clear and more valuable if the sentence
allows them to think about what they
care about. And a passive verb does
this. When you use are permitted, it
allows you to take business and move it
over here to the topic position. Yes,
it's longer and yes, it uses a passive
verb, but it's more valuable to readers
because it lets them think about what
they care about. Or let's say you're
writing a newsletter about finance like
Ben Thompson. You have a sentence like
seasonal volatility of intermediated
consumption directly affects price
dividend ratios. All right, so imagine
that your readers are investors. They
want to use price dividend ratios to
make investment decisions. They only
want to know about the volatility in so
far as it relates to the thing that they
care about, which is the ratios. So, a
sentence is likely to seem more clear to
them and crucially more valuable to them
if what they care about is what the
sentence is about. Or one more example
from thought leadership. Here's Eric
Reese, the author of the lean startup.
Matt Mullenweg offered every automatic
employee 6 months of salary to resign if
they didn't believe in the company's
direction. Now, I suppose it's possible
that readers do want to know about Matt
Mullen. But it's easy to imagine readers
who don't primarily care about Mullenweg
as well. But what they do care about is
receiving six month salary. That is if
they're the workforce or if the readers
are more from company management, then
you can imagine that those readers care
about the company's direction and how to
get employees to believe in it. So, in
all cases, the fix couldn't be easier if
you just let yourself do it. Just go
ahead and use the sentence with more
words and passive verbs if it helps your
readers. Now, readers who want to think
about honey are getting a sentence that
gives them what they want. And so, the
sentence seems more clear and more
importantly more valuable. But how are
you supposed to know what your readers
want to read about? Now, you can usually
make a pretty good guess about your
readers. I mean, do you really think
that your clients want to read about the
new feature of your product? But often
you can't know for sure. So, I'm using
the word guess here because I realize
that many experts find it stressful to
have this uncertainty in their writing.
So, one of the attractions of rules like
avoid passive verbs or always write in
shorter sentences is that rules create
the illusion of certainty. I mean, if
you've got a rule and you follow it,
then at the very least, you're certain
that you followed the rule. And of
course, you can automate the execution
of these rules to unthinking tools like
AI. And to be totally forthcoming, I
should just say that if thinking of
writing as a matter of rules gets you to
successful writing, then I don't want to
meddle. If it ain't broke, don't fix it.
Simply in the name of my commitment to a
particular philosophy of language, which
says that writing isn't a thing, it's a
function. All right? So, the meaning of
your writing doesn't exist in the text
itself. the way that oxygen exists in
water. Instead, meaning arises from what
readers do when they engage with your
writing. So, the text's meaning exists
in the reader in how they use it,
process it, apply to it, respond to it,
and reject it. So, following the rules
works for your readers, then carry on.
But I do, however, want to meddle if
you're telling other people to follow
those rules. In my teaching and private
consultations, I spend a lot of time
showing experts that these writing
mavens themselves very often don't apply
the rules that they claim are rules.
Now, the mavens will respond to this by
saying, "Well, there are exceptions, of
course, and those mavens have an alarm
bell in their head that goes off when
following a rule makes their writing
worse." The trouble is that unlike those
writing mavens, not everybody has those
alarm bells. I mean most experts have
devoted their time to developing domain
expertise in their field. So they don't
have time to also master all the
intricacies of writing. So while writing
rules may make it easier for the mavens
to teach, they should be wary of
imposing those rules on others because
there are no writing rules. There are
only writing tools. So how do you know
what your readers want to think about?
How do you know what to use as the
subjects of your sentences? Well, you've
got many ways to think about this, but
here I'll just suggest that you consider
how readers would phrase a question they
heard about your writing. So, think
backwards about what you've written.
Take a sentence and then think of that
sentence as the answer to a question.
Then put that question into your
reader's voice. How would the reader
phrase that question? What would they
use as the subject of that question? So
take the sentence, Matt Mullenwig
offered every automatic employee six
months of salary to resign if they
didn't believe in the company's
direction. And now imagine this sentence
as the answer to a question. How would
your readers phrase that question? What
would they use as the subject of their
question? Some readers, especially if
they're in management, might ask, "Can
company loyalty be tested by offering
employees salary to leave?" Well, in
that case, the better sentence is
commitment to the company's direction
was tested by Matt Mullenweg, who
offered every automatic employee who
didn't believe in it 6 months of salary
to resign. But if your readers are part
of the workforce and they're more
interested in salary, their question
might be something like why was 6 months
salary offered to the employees? to
which a good answer would be six months
of salary was offered by Matt Mullenweg
to every automatic employee to resign if
they didn't believe in the company's
direction. Now honestly there are even a
few readers who would ask what did Matt
Mullenweg do? Like at specific moments
in specific niches readers are
interested in what other experts in
their field have said. But even in these
moments, you shouldn't assume that your
readers care most about Matt Mullenwick.
Very often, even when readers do want to
know what someone else has said about a
topic, they don't care who said it. So
here, they may well care less about
Mullenwag and much more about the salary
or the company loyalty. In other words,
they might not ask, "What did Matt
Mullen do?" They might instead ask
something like, "Did his offer work?" or
did the employees take his offer? All
right. Now, earlier I told you about the
two dangers of rules like shorter is
better and avoid passives. And one
danger was that such a rule will cause a
specific writing failure. That is
following rules without creating value.
But another deeper danger lies in the
habit of thinking about your writing in
terms of rules. That can be a deadly
habit because it can get in your way of
thinking about readers. If you are among
the many experts for whom the rules of
writing have been ingrained, then your
habits cause you not to think about your
particular readers for your particular
text. Rules or these AI agents lead you
to assume that all readers are the same.
Shorter is better for all readers.
active verbs are clearer for all readers
and so on. But in my teaching and my
private consulting, I bump into this
problem all the time. I've worked with
countless writers who are so trained in
applying rules or outsourcing their
thinking about writing to AI that they
resist thinking about their specific
readers. And for these writers, there's
no point in thinking about your readers
because the rules have already
established what the writing should be
like. And what's worse, these writers
become downright suspicious of thinking
about readers at all because the
thinking pulls them away from what they
know is true, which is the rules. And at
that point, writing rules do indeed
become dangerous because it stops your
writing from performing its professional
functions. The writing doesn't work.
When your writing succeeds, it succeeds
with particular readers, not because it
follows generalized rules, especially
when those rules are wrong. So, it's
back to the bees and the honey. Some
readers care about the bees and they
want to read about the bees. Other
readers care about the honey and they
want to read about the honey. But keep
in mind that this has been about the
function of language for readers and
about how you revise your writing for
those specific readers. But writing
serves writers and readers differently.
And you shouldn't pay attention to any
of this stuff during your first draft.
So watch this video next because it's
going to show you what to focus on
instead during the first function of
writing while you're using your writing
to serve your own thinking. So, be sure
to go check it out.